-I want to say congrats on
"White Lotus."
I want to talk about it
because you just nailed it.
I mean, it was a home run,
buddy.
You are so good in that.
But before we get into that,
I want to say that we've had
many guests on our show that
have done impressions of you.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and great ones.
-Who would have thought?
[ Laughter ]
-But if you're up for it,
I'd love to show
a few of these impressions.
-Oh, yeah. I think I know --
I know some great ones
I've seen on Instagram.
Okay, yeah. Who do you got?
-Chloe Fineman was here.
-Oh, my God.
-Here's her Jennifer Coolidge
impression.
-Oh, I'm going to make you
a pie, dumbass!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Is that amazing?
-It is. It's amazing.
You know, it's so weird
because you don't really know
who you are ever, really,
you know, in an objective point
you know, sort of perspective.
But then you see people and
you're like, "That's who I am?"
[ Laughter ]
They do you and you're like,
"Oh, alright. I'll take it."
I mean, she -- I liked that.
-But when you get in the zone.
But the first time I think
I heard anyone do an impression
of you is when Ariana Grande was
here a few years ago.
And here's Ariana's impression
of Jennifer.
-God, you look like
the Fourth of July.
I'm taking the dog, dumbass.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-Come on!
-Ariana Grande crushing it.
That's a great impression.
-I know. Unbelievable.
But, you know, you should know
that it was sort of
the beginning of a lot of cool
things that happened for me
because -- I don't know --
I sort of, you know,
I was going through a dead zone.
And not much was going on.
And then Ariana did
this imitation on your show,
and you encouraged her.
And then this ball got rolling.
I mean, you know, my friend
who's like her age, Teresa,
she was like, "Hey, you know,
you should DM Ariana
and just say, you know --"
because I thought it was
such a good imitation.
And I was like, "No, she's got
like 260 million followers.
Those are robots.
The robots answer the DMs
and we will never ever
get to her, whatever."
And then I did it anyway and
then this response came back.
And then, next thing you know,
I was going to her house
getting fit for a wardrobe
fitting for "Thank U, Next."
So that was all because of
Jimmy Fallon. Yes.